Speaker 1: Roger Stone is the former Trump
confidant aide who has also been a guest on
this program.
Roger Stone, of course, was convicted and
then pardoned by Donald Trump.
Roger Stone has a new hypothesis, which is
that it is the Secret Service that was somehow
involved in the Trump riots on January 6th.
Now, I have to admit, we're going to look
at a clip of this.
And if I'm totally honest with you, I don't
fully understand the conspiracy theory here.
And I kind of love it in the sense that one
of my favorite things is a conspiracy theory
that doesn't even make any sense.
Like it's hard to even understand.
There's lots of conspiracy theories where
you hear it and you say that just doesn't
sound like it's really the way things are.
But this is one where I'm left asking, what
exactly is Roger Stone even arguing here?
So let's start taking a listen.
This is Roger Stone on a Newsmax.
I'm not even sure what he's claiming took
place, but it involves the Secret Service.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 4: I call it fake news.
Say, Roger, did you on January six, did you
go in the building?
I would never even left the grounds of the
Willard Hotel.
Yeah, I'm out in front of the hotel in the
morning for a brief period to stretch my legs.
You can watch the entire video.
A number of patriots come up and ask for selfies
or patriots.
Speaker 1: Yeah, patriots.
Really?
Why he's popular with the Patriot movement
on
Speaker 4: me, that they're praying for me.
But no, I was not even on the capital.
I do find it odd that shortly after the president's
speech, the Secret Service contacted someone
who worked for me by phone and told me that
they wanted to escort me to the Capitol.
I declined.
I was.
What do you think that was about?
Speaker 1: So I guess now what Stone is saying
is an unprovoked call from the Secret Service,
saying we'd like to bring you to the capital
would maybe be to to implicate Stone.
Maybe that's what they're saying, that they
wanted to place Stone there to then implicate
him in the riots, even though he didn't have
anything to do with it.
Tell me if that's how you're understanding
this
Speaker 4: when you say that it was there
something about that that sounded fishy?
Well, I work for three American presidents.
The Secret Service does not do political chores.
The Secret Service does not perform logistical
tasks.
I find it rather suspicious, to be honest
and suspicious.
In what way do you
Speaker 1: like even the hosts are sort of
unsure.
Like what exactly are you alleging here?
Speaker 5: Is that perhaps insiders I'm trying
to figure out how to word this within the
Secret Service of the CIA or other organizations
were involved nefariously.
Speaker 4: Look, I don't wanna to make that
claim because I don't know it, but but understanding
how the Secret Service works, obviously, the
implication is that this is something the
president wanted.
I'm sorry I declined.
I was with Pastor Mark Burns and Reverend
Randy Coggins right in my suite, watching
the whole thing unfold on television.
Speaker 1: Right.
So my other question.
Yeah, making the case.
So I guess the conspiracy theory is the Secret
Service.
So Tucker Carlson and others have been saying
it's the FBI that was involved in the Trump
riots.
Roger Stone is saying, I believe, again, we
have to interpret it all because he's being
kind of cagey and weird about it.
But he's saying the Secret Service, which
would not normally be involved in something
like this, tried to put me at the scene of
the crime in order for me to later be implicated
or something like that.
Now, of course, we don't actually have proof
that this call even took place.
If it did take place.
We don't have proof that
it was actually the Secret Service.
There's no evidence for any of this, but it
is another one of these conspiracy theories
presented without any evidence.
And we'll see if this one also becomes part
of the referential record.
Remember, with Tucker Carlson, Tucker floated
this idea that the FBI organized the
Trump riots and then the next day, Congressman
Louie Gohmert demanded we look into it, even
though Tucker presented it without any evidence.
That's how they do it.
That's how they insert narratives as fact,
which then become referential in their future
claims.
We'll see if it happens with this one.
But that's the latest claim from Roger Stone,
the Secret Service.
It sounds like everybody other than actual
Trump was involved.
It was the Secret Service, it was the FBI.
It was antifa dressed as Trump.
But definitely no, Trump is.
But at the same time, it was totally peaceful.
Figure that one out.